you pathetic you're only good for buying
me a drink you cook you know I have a
boyfriend you're still gonna buy I'll
take your money and I'll take your drink
thank you very much because I came here
I didn't even bring cash because I knew
there was going to be losers like you to
buy me drinks all night and I'm coming
back tomorrow and after tomorrow and all
you little loser cuts are gonna be here
that's how they thinking maybe not as
Extreme as me I added a little extra
extra that was a little bit of sauce
[Music]
that's the DMX song I
know it sorry
am I alive just literally Replay that
same audio just remove the visual and
don't it sound like he's the same [ __ ]
in the dark just saying different names
Kylie Jordan Natalie Courtney Olivia
Sophia Gabriella Alexa Sophia Victoria
Austin Sarah Ivy Lily Ellie Maddie Mia
Sarah Tyra Courtney Olivia Sophie taliba
Jamie Felix Serena Sarah Gail mail what
Gail
Caroline Tabitha Mary Cherry Jane moan
Siobhan oh no no no you went moan yeah
moan
moan moan m-o-a-n that's cat that's cat
that's cat that's cap chat he did seven
and then he had to give up moan m-o-a-m
this guy's gonna look up the name don't
even lie chat put a wonder if you think
Moon's a real name that y'all seen from
white girls put a two if you disagree no
yeah don't even try don't even try don't
even try don't even Google said yeah
yeah midi Grizzly oh man duh Leah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
are you buying your own drinks never no
no no
no never never ever oh yeah 90 of the
time now no yes
I buy my own drinks I respect that I
like that no the man will buy them for
you stop it
no yes I do usually a guy buys them for
me I mean tonight yeah there's no men
here
you're barely a girl shut up
bam all right preach yeah yeah yes
always yeah barely yes I always buy my
own drink we've bought in our own drinks
gotta have your own money but if someone
offers you a drink I'm not gonna say no
how are you getting these drinks people
buy them for me who's people guys how
are you getting your drinks men y'all
are paying for her drinks yeah they are
you find an old man
sugar daddy a sugar daddy someone buys
them for me you'll have to either pop a
titty
you be popping titties for drinks damn I
ain't never ever happened to me I'm
trying to see what that be like eighty
percent someone else buys them for me
who's someone else a guy so how are you
getting these drinks you want to stop
for your drinks interesting people buy
them those people there's random people
who come up to me if you're not buying
your own drinks how are you getting
drinks my good charm my lovely
personality what person who's got her
face she knows I'm not gonna buy a girl
a drink if she has zero intentions of
hooking up with me yeah God told you
that guy I'm like okay but I have no
just like I have a boyfriend they're
like okay can I just buy a dragon yep
what oh yeah oh yeah
because you have to understand
the penis is a dreamer
right the Mind understands what is
the penis understands who it could be
inside
and then it dreams of who it couldn't be
inside and then it sends a signal to the
brain says [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up right
and the penis continues its dream it
says [ __ ] believe since you were a
child you knew that you could achieve
and it starts rhyming hey she got two
titties we got two balls let's go to the
basketball play some [ __ ] balls right
like the penis just make shut up and it
don't make no sense but it talks enough
that the testosterone in your blood's
like hey man that nigga's speaking facts
listen
listen listen the penis is that trash
ass New York rapper who don't know how
to run but got a whole row of [ __ ] who
still gonna go ooh whenever he does a
shitty bar right so you start buying
into the hype too the penis is a dreamer
what the penis believes the penis
believes the penis is just like
hey guys I'm kind of cold not gonna be
warm in there
I don't know maybe your penis place
doesn't Dragon mine mine is assertivus
[ __ ] to it
[ __ ] you've always wanted to do it look
at her look at her look at the way she
just touched her hair she wants to put
that hair around your dick that's how
the Venus works so when I hear when the
dick Hears A girl say but I got a
boyfriend the [ __ ] the dick is like
yeah here right now is he girl you need
this dick and balls in you right I got a
boyfriend oh so you like guys
[Music]
he's gonna switch it up the deposit yeah
so I don't care none of this matters
you're just have to get the drink and go
grab a drink and go I don't have any
intention doing anything with them but I
definitely stare at the drink before
they give it to me what you won't be
able to tell if a drink is drug you know
that right I have eyes of a hawk I'd be
able to tell no no no no
[Music]
no you won't shut up it's the ones that
act like
Nabi the more you sure about your [ __ ]
the more this [ __ ] is promote prone to
happen to you trust me do y'all ever
take drinks from men that y'all aren't
interested in yeah oh yeah y'all don't
feel bad about that no I do sometimes
that's a real friendly real friends
[ __ ] don't even try it let's be
Shameless [ __ ] you lying you have any
intentions on getting with the guy nope
he just bought them for me no and I say
it though and they still buy you things
yes it's pretty unfortunate it's pretty
sad somebody back are you interested in
that guy or you just take the drink no
stop buying lemon drink
okay let me let me ask you this okay and
I think I want the audience to answer
along with me okay I'm asking these
questions guys when you see this do you
see that these men are desperate
that's actually a great question because
I'm asking myself that every time I wake
up in the morning
so my question
do you guys see these men who go up and
buy these drinks for women who have zero
intentions and most guys know but they
still they're praying do you see these
guys as desperate
most you probably answered yes these
guys were desperate that's why they're
buying drinks for women who are never
going to look their way look how look
how disgusted these women are they've
given these guys the same look they've
pretty much laughed in their face
sometimes wow
I wouldn't say that they're desperate
they just
which is desperate because no guy would
be doing that if they didn't feel like
they had to
no but not no no I don't think it's just
wait maybe I just didn't say that
properly
that's not what is that what they got to
but
it's the thing
it's kind of the sex the the the the
social thing to do
that the thing that we
we understand in society guys by drink
you see a girl you buy a drink
they don't have a way to start a
conversation and that's an easy opener
maybe not a good one but I wouldn't say
that didn't necessary but desperate
that's just me but someone that buys a
drink to those girls is honestly
desperate
he's just if you try and shoot you shot
you're not gonna see desperate you're
just shooting shot to see what's going
on do you have any intentions on getting
with the guy no but he just bought them
for me no and I say it though and they
still buy you things yes it's pretty
unfortunate it's pretty it's sad really
when those girls are siphoning tricks
from most of the dudes out there that
those dudes are not hoping for more
yeah but it doesn't mean that they're
dead hold up they're hoping for more
correct yeah they don't get more and
they have that experience repeatedly all
these women pretty much said I'm never
going back anywhere with these dudes I'm
zero interest in them so that means that
mostly dudes running around trying to
buy these girls drinks or having little
to no success rate
foreign
Maybe
I I when I used to go to clubs and you
see the dudes running around buying
girls drinks where the [ __ ] are not
getting laid
it is what it is the reason why you're
buying them drinks is because you ain't
got game
at the club if you are here once you
start going around buying these
groceries you know what they look at you
as a cash cow that's what they're doing
and so that's why these guys do that the
moment a dude is really really desirable
you see these guys going around trying
to buy these girls drinks of course not
they don't have to they don't have to
they don't have to because they don't
have to spend that kind of money and do
all that stuff because the woman's
already interested dudes would never buy
these girls drinks if it wasn't
necessarily the social contract so
they're
desperate because of my social contract
the dudes who have to go to the club and
buy women drinks and spend all that
money on getting them drinks or the
dudes were not getting any
if you getting some you don't have to do
that most of the time if you gain some
you don't even have to show it to the
club but if you do you're certainly not
running around you let me buy a drink so
I could talk to what
that is if you already know how to
approach ladies you already know that's
the worst way to do it because they
already look at you one way you're the
same as the last 10 pathetic losers who
gave me the same opener which is let me
buy you a drink
now here's nothing
if a girl liked you or she thought you
were cute you don't even have to buy her
a drink if you just go up to her and
talk to her and act different you've
already stood out it's actually
counter-intuitive to go up and buy them
a drink like every other loser who's
tried the same night
now of course if you're in the flow of a
conversation with somebody who's A vibe
maybe you guys that's different and if
I'm wrong ladies let me know in the
comments below when you guys are at a
nightclub and the dude runs up on you
he's like let me buy you a drink what is
your first thought in your head aside
from a free drink are you looking at
this dude and thinking wow
probably not and you want to know why I
know that's true because the girls who
were asked this question when he buys
you a drink would you go back with them
they didn't think back to all the guys
who bought them drinks and they thought
was cute they're thinking about the
hundreds
because these girls go out every weekend
that's hundreds and they're getting
drinks every weekend they don't pay for
a single one good thing about the
hundreds of dudes who bought them drinks
and they wanted nothing to do with
that's hundreds
no
I'll bet I ain't done the whole club
thing since I was 20 that's seven years
ago for me okay I doubt it's changed
already you're working 10 steps back
and the reason why I bring all this up
the reason why dudes are in women's DMS
famous women sending all this stuff
talking to these ladies the reason why
dudes and only fans is exploded and
dudes are sending all their money even
though they're broke or they're pretty
much living at the poverty line the
reason why all these guys because men
are desperate
men are incredibly desperate for some
either coochie or a separated affection
some of these dudes really want
girlfriends a lot of them do sometimes
just want human contact you feel me
I just want to appreciate
oftentimes
we talk about
taking advantage of people and power
dynamics but one thing we never do in
society is talk about the sway that
beautiful women have over men
that's all I'm not saying that taking a
drink from someone is the same as a boss
banging his secretary I'm not saying
that I'm saying the same thing that
leads men to buy these women drinks and
do that is the same [ __ ] that believes a
lot of these men to go up on these only
fans and spend all their money okay for
a little bit of human interaction even
though these women know what these guys
are there for even though these women
don't give a [ __ ] about these dudes but
just want to get their money and they're
taking advantage of them nobody cares
nobody cares even look at they're
talking with disgust when they're
talking about these guys you're
interested in that guy or you just take
the drink no do you all have any
intention on being with these men
you just have to get the drink and go
grab a drink and go do you have any
intentions on getting with the guy no
but he just bought them for me no and I
say it though and they still buy you
things yes it's pretty unfortunate it's
pretty sad they are they here these
names they're like poof
right that's what they're saying in
their mind you pathetic you're only good
for buying me a drink you cuck you know
I have a boyfriend you're still gonna
buy I'll take your money and I'll take
your drink thank you very much because I
came here I didn't even bring cash
because I knew there was going to be
losers like you to buy me drinks all
night and I'm coming back tomorrow and
after tomorrow and all you [ __ ]
little loser cooks are gonna be here
that's how they think it maybe not as
Extreme as me I added a little extra
extra that was a little bit of sauce but
you get what I'm but that's the feeling
but
I mean you were not too far off
they think you're a loser so if you're
watching this as a dude stop Behind
these ladies drinks it won't stop stop
by and if a woman's like no what what
are you arguing that it's men's place in
society to go out to a nightclub and
finance your night
a woman he doesn't even know you better
not be trying to come at me with that
[ __ ]
they're gonna come at you at least a
stripper gives the man a lap dance what
the [ __ ] is you doing giving him a glaze
that's a transaction no glance of what
no full barricade no
stop guys
stop they're not gonna and listen ladies
will talk about power dynamics all they
want beautiful women will use their [ __ ]
to their advantage any change they
[ __ ] get so many of them will
so many of them will and they won't even
think twice about it a lot of them don't
even know
you think these women know
hold up I think some of them know they
don't know they don't care they know
they don't care they don't care they
don't care they don't care when they're
doing these only fans you think they
care no
come on bro
come on bro well I'm not forcing them to
do it so that's why they don't care I
can use that logic for a lot of things
but you know power dynamics I'm just
saying
I'm the same
I'm not saying I'm out here feeling a
bunch of sympathy for these
for these slopes no no it's not slippers
you heard it you could print it off on
the screen I'm just saying I'm just
saying and I'm not sitting here crying
for these dudes or being able to heart
no if these dudes want to go out and
spend their money stupidly that's their
business that's them but take that out
and hold that out dudes but ladies I'm
just saying appreciate the entitlement
of these ladies and the fact that men
acquiesce out of desperation does that
not sound a little predatory just
because she's not built like a
linebacker don't mean she can't be
deadly with her [ __ ] predatory she's not
going after
what she's not going after the mans what
do you mean she's letting them do it I'm
under depression and that a predator to
be a predator you have to prey on them
you have to go at it and get them so in
this case the way people see it
is a guy that are predators because
they're trying to get the curls it's
just the girls are not gonna Butch and
say no they're not gonna push and say
yes but
they're using
their prey likes to get what they want
but it's not
I just I just I just said it out loud
and this is what it is I just said it
out loud go ahead and is it at the end
of the day you're being a predator
because you still taking advantage at
the end of the day when I'm saying
predatory I'm not saying these people
are predators or like some kind of I'm
not trying to use a crazy word what I'm
trying to say is okay you go to the club
knowing you're not gonna spend money
yeah you go to the club looking for
these dudes you dress in a certain type
of way to be a little bit Yeah I do it
for the dude sure they're not but
they're going out there expecting their
drinks let me tell you uh you need
dresses like a nun to go to the club and
there's a reason yeah okay especially
when you accept these drinks there's a
reason anybody trying to tell me
otherwise when her titties are out oh
they love me for my personality my charm
she starts she knows what she doing
I'm not even mad I'm just saying let's
not put a veneer of like yeah it's me
let's not pretend because you attracted
basically you basically the reason why
they're Predators I just said it out
loud and I figure out sometimes I have
to say it out loud and figure it out I
just see they attracted and they took
advantage of I'm not listen it's
important to say this I don't want this
word to mean nothing when I'm saying
they're being practical I'm just saying
these things that they out there
I'm not saying the Predators okay what I
am trying to say they are taking
advantage of people that little kids
have the same ammo
they attract and they take advantage how
are they gonna go that dramatic but okay
I did I mean it's the same it's a
different degree I get it but I mean I
said it out loud and I'm like no they
attract and then they take advantage of
them I'm like yes I'm so disappointed in
you though oh yeah you're going to go
your best friend a day after breaking up
with your boyfriend
that means you wanted to [ __ ] your best
friend while you were dating your
boyfriend
[Music]
it's kind of more complicated like it's
not complicated okay
you can Wanna [ __ ] a couple of times
people really think that oh I Wanna [ __ ]
one person I like that's one person I
don't know what kind of romance land you
live but that's not how it works there's
a lot of people that you could be
attracted to that [ __ ] look good
that [ __ ] look good that
[ __ ] look good but you like you
got that one piece that's your main
piece you understand so you do your
thing right there and my girl no it's
not complicated stop stop you just don't
want to look bad okay you don't want to
be called
whatever okay knock knock who's there
poor you know I mean you don't want to
be calling into that but at the end of
the day at the end of the day let's not
I don't know what kind of La La Land is
no no it's just me you thinking about me
all the time you think about me every
day I'm the one I'm the it doesn't work
like that guys maybe I'm the only one
but it doesn't work like that okay
there's a lot of [ __ ] that you
could look while still doing your thing
come on now B I'll watch that I'm like
just just hearing how disgusted they are
by these men it's like damn you think of
these people as like sub-human almost
like losers
interested interesting but I digress
maybe you guys disagree you see it
differently maybe you like buying girls
drinks you know what I mean whatever it
might be we want to hear from you let us
know